immortan Clive Double Down Ruggles
I'm Daniel Tate I am your parole officer
and I just want to help you how the hell
you supposed to help me man
what do you know about the streets what
would you diplomas on the wall settle
down I know that you might not be able
to relate to me but I think I know
somebody who you can relate to little
homie no listen a man ain't trying to
talk to no puppet man it's not a puppet
it's little homie I would like free to
talk to him Clive see I used to work in
the juvenile correction systems and I
found this method very effective I know
juvenile man okay see what look it's
very important for your parole that you
talk to little homie sup low homie what
you getting into these days man what it
is what it is you got a job yet I'm
trying man but no one will hire me yeah
hey God that noise man between you and
me man ain't nobody trying to hide the
with a record play man what you need to
be doing is get back into some crimes
mang what what's going on man are you
talking to me yeah well you should be
talking to little homie right yeah [ __ ]
talk to me give me what I'm talking to
you okay okay okay fine
[Music]
so you smoking weed no man no no no
homie I'm done with drugs smoke this
weed no no no no no no man I'm done man
you hear me I'm done with drugs I ain't
doing all that I don't know
little homie seems pretty serious about
that here look I'm confused man what do
you want me to do we well I want you to
clean up your act but you're not talking
to me right now you're talking to little
homie he's not messing around
I think I think you better do what he
says no homie man just relax man relax
little homie take it easy I'm just
almost smoke it down
wait wait no no no no no no you can't
fool me are you trying to trick me man
no no I'm done with the weed you in this
with me now right okay little homie yeah
you failed the test I have no choice but
to revoke your parole
what Oh make this about a [ __ ] on your
feet baby boy get him out of here come
on
I can't believe that negrumps actually
thought I killed you I don't know right
you